it's been I think two years since we
last talked and in that time you somehow
went and co-created a new programming
language called Mojo uh so it's
optimized for AI it's a superset of
python let's look at the big picture
what is division uh for Mojo from Mojo
well so I mean I think you have to zoom
out so I've been working on a lot of
related Technologies for many many years
so I've worked on llvm and a lot of
things and mobile and servers and things
like this
but the world's changing and what's
happened with AI is we have new gpus and
new
machine learning accelerators and other
Asics and things like that that make ai
go real fast at Google I worked on tpus
that's one of the biggest larger scale
deployed systems that exist for AI and
really what you see is if you look
across all of the things that are
happening in the industry there's this
new compute platform coming and it's not
just about
CPUs or gpus or tpus or npus or ipus or
whatever all the pus right it's about
how do we program these things
right and so for software folks like us
right it doesn't do us any good if
there's this amazing Hardware that we
can't use
and one of the things you find out
really quick is that having the
theoretical capability of programming
something and then having the world's
power and the innovation of all the all
the smart people in the world get
Unleashed on something can be quite
different and so really where Mojo came
from was starting from a problem of we
need to be able to take machine learning
take the infrastructure underneath it
and make it way more accessible way more
usable way more understandable by normal
people and researchers and other folks
that are not themselves like experts in
gpus and things like this and then
through that Journey we realized hey we
need Syntax for this we need to do a
programming language so one one of the
the main features of the language I say
so fully ingest is that it allows you to
have the file extension to be uh an
emoji or the fire Emoji which is
one of the first
emojis used as a file extension I've
ever seen in my life and then you ask
yourself the question why in the 21st
century are we not using Unicode for
file extensions this I mean it's an epic
decision I think clearly the most
important decision you made in the most
but but you could also just use mojo as
the file extension well so okay so take
a step back I mean come on Max do you
think that the world's ready for this
this is a big moment in the world right
this is we'll release this onto the work
this is innovation
I mean it really is kind of brilliant
emojis is such a big part of our daily
lives why is it not in programming well
and and like you take a step back and
look look at what file extensions are
right they're basically metadata right
and so why are we spending all the
screen space on them and all the stuff
also you know you have them stacked up
next to text files and PDF files and
whatever else like if you're gonna do
something cool you want to stand out
right and emojis are colorful they're
visual they're they're beautiful yeah
right what's been the response so far
from uh is is there support on like
Windows on the operating system in
displaying like file explorer yeah the
one problem I've seen is the git doesn't
escape it right and so it thinks that
the fire Emoji is unprintable and so it
like prints out weird hex things if you
use a command line git tool but
everything else as far as I'm aware
works fine and I I have faith that git
can be improved so GitHub is fine GitHub
is fine yep GitHub is fine Visual Studio
code Windows like all this stuff totally
ready because people have
internationalization yeah in their
normal part of their past
so let's just like taking the next step
right
somewhere between oh wow that makes
sense cool I like new things too
oh my God you're killing my baby like
what are you talking about this could
never be like I can never handle this
how am I going to type this this is just
like all these things and so this is
something where I think that the world
will get there we don't have to bet the
whole Farm on this I think we can
provide both paths but I think it'll be
great uh when can we have emojis as part
of the code I wonder uh yeah so I mean
lots of languages provide that so um I
think that we have personal support for
that it's probably not fully done yet
but but yeah you can you can do that for
example in Swift you can do that for
sure so an example we give give it Apple
was the the dog cow yeah so that's a
classical Mac Heritage thing and so he's
the dog and the cow emoji together and
that could be your variable name but of
course the internet went and made pile
of poop for everything yeah so you know
if you want to name your function pile
of poop then you can totally go to town
and see how that gets through code
review
okay so uh let me just ask a bunch of
random questions uh so is Mojo primarily
designed for aisle or is it a general
purpose programming yeah good question
so it's AI first and so AI is driving a
lot of the requirements and so
um modular is building and designing and
driving Mojo forward and it's not
because it's an interesting project
theoretically to build it's because we
need it
that's what modular we're really
tackling the AI infrastructure landscape
and the big problems in Ai and the
reasons it is so difficult to use in
scale and adopt and deploy and like all
these big problems in Ai and so we're
coming out from that perspective now
when you do that when you start tackling
these problems you realize that the
solution to these problems isn't
actually an AI specific solution
and so what we're doing this we're
building Mojo to be a fully General
programming language and that means that
you can
obviously tackle gpus and CPUs and like
these AI things but it's also a really
great way to build
numpy and other things like that or you
know just if you look at what many
python libraries are today often they're
a layer of python for the API and they
end up being C and C plus plus code
underneath them that's very true in AI
That's True in lots of other domains as
well and so anytime you see this pattern
that's an opportunity for Mojo to help
simplify the world and help people have
one thing to optimize through
simplification
by having one thing so you mentioned
modular Mojo is the programming language
modular is the whole software stack so
just over a year ago we started this
company called modular yeah okay what
modular is about is it's about taking Ai
and up leveling it into the Next
Generation right and so if you take a
step back what's gone on in the last
five six seven eight years is that we've
had things like tensorflow and pytorch
and these other systems come in you've
used them you know this and what's
happened is these things have grown like
crazy they get tons of users it's in
production deployment scenarios it's
being used to power so many systems I
mean AIS all around us now now it used
to be controversial years ago but now
it's a thing but the challenge with
these systems is that they haven't
always been
um thought out with current demands in
mind so you think about it when where
were llms eight years ago well they
didn't exist right AI has changed so
much and a lot of what people are doing
today are very different than when these
were built and meanwhile the hardware
side of this has gone into a huge mess
there's tons of new chips and
accelerators and every every big
company's announcing a new chip every
day it feels like and so between that
you have like this moving system on one
side a moving system on the other side
and it just turns into this gigantic
mess which makes it very difficult for
people to actually use AI particularly
in production deployment scenarios
that's what modular is doing is we're
helping build out that software stack to
help solve some of those problems so
then people can be more productive and
get more AI Research into production
now what Mojo does is it's a really
really important piece of that and so
that is you know part of that engine and
part of the technology that allows us to
solve these problems so Mojo is a
programming language that
allows you to do a higher level
programming the low level programming
like do all kinds of programming
in that spectrum that gets you closer
and closer to the hardware so take step
back so let's what do you love about
python oh boy
where do I begin
um what is love what do I love about
python your guy who knows love I know
this yes
um
how intuitive it is
thank you
how it feels like I'm writing natural
language English
uh
how when I can not just write but read
other people's code somehow I can
understand it faster it's more
condensed than other languages like ones
I'm really familiar with like C plus
plus and C uh there's a bunch of sexy
little features yeah uh we'll probably
talk about some of them but list
comprehensions and stuff like this uh
well so and and don't forget the entire
ecosystem of all the Packers oh yeah
there's probably huge there's always
something if you want to do anything
there's always a package yeah so it's
not just
the ecosystem of the packages and the
ecosystem of the humans that do it that
that's a really
that's an interesting dynamic because I
think something
about the the usability and the
ecosystem makes the thing viral it grows
and then it's a virtuous cycle I think
well there's many things that went into
that like so I think that ml was very
good for Python and so I think that
tensorflow and Pi torsion these systems
embracing python really took and help
python grow but I think that the major
thing underlying it is that Python's
like the universal connector right it
really helps bring together lots of
different systems so you can compose
them and build out larger systems
without having to understand how it
works but then what is the problem with
python well I guess you could say
several things but probably that it's
slow
I think that's usually what people
complain about right and so so I mean
other people complain about tabs in
spaces versus curly braces or whatever
but I mean those people are just wrong
because it is actually just better to
use indentation
wow strong words so actually I just have
a small tangent let's actually take that
let's take all kinds of tangents oh come
on Lex you can push me on I could take
nine and decide listen I've recently
left emacs for vs code the kind of hate
mail I had to receive because on the way
to doing that I also said I've
considered Vim yep and uh chose not to
and went with vs code and touching on
deep religions right